-
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE ON JEROME
POWELL IN THE NEXT 25 MINUTES.
RUSSIA SEES --
SAYS IS REJOINING THE UKRAINE
GRAIN DEAL.
THAT MEANS MOSCOW NOT GUARANTEE
SAFE PASSAGE FOR CARGO SHIPS
TRAVELING FROM UKRAINIAN PORTS
THROUGH THE BLACK SEA.
IN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
TONS OF FOOD EXPORTS GO WHERE
THEY'RE MOST NEEDED.
IT'S A SUDDEN ABOUT FACE, LET'S
SAY THAT, JUST DAYS AFTER
RUSSIA SAID A SUSPENDING ITS
PARTICIPATION.
IT COMES AFTER RUSSIA'S
PRESIDENT SPOKE WEDNESDAY WITH
HIS TURKISH COUNTERPART.
LET'S GO NOW TO --
A SPOKESPERSON FOR TURKISH
PRESIDENT --
WELL KNOWN FACE OF THE SHOW.
SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK ON
THE SHOW.
AN IMPORTANT DAY TO HAVE YOUR
EXPERTISE.
EXPLAIN THIS BACK AND FORTH TO
OUR VIEWERS AROUND THE WORLD
FROM RUSSIA.
IT WAS IN, THEN IT WAS OUT FOR
DAYS AGO.
IN ITS NOW BACK IN AGAIN.
>> YES, WE'RE VERY HAPPY THAT
RUSSIA'S BACK IN THE PROCESS.
THEY'VE SUSPENDED THEIR PART OF
THE AGREEMENT ON SATURDAY AFTER
AN ATTNE OF THEIR SHIPS
IN THE --
AREA THEY COMPLAINED, THEY
PROTESTED, THE WROTE LETTERS TO
THE UN.
AND WE SPOKE TO THEM
IMMEDIATELY.
WE CONTACTED THEM BECAUSE THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THIS IS SEPARATE FROM THE WAR.
EVERYTHING IS LIGHT RELATED TO
THE WAR BUT SENDING THE GRAIN
THAT IS NEEDED TO PLACES WE
HAVE JUST POINTED OUT IS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE FOR
EVERYONE.
SO FOR THE LAST THREE, FOUR
DAYS WE HAVE EXERTED A LOT OF
DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS.
OUR DEFENSE MINISTER, FOREIGN
MINISTER, EVENTUALLY OUR
PRESIDENT SPOKE TO PRESIDENT
PUTIN YESTERDAY.
WHEN THEY SPOKE, PRESIDENT
PUTIN RIGHTLY RAISED SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS ATTACK.
WHY IT WAS DONE IN THEIR
ASSESSMENT --
THE ATTACKERS USED THE CORRIDOR
FOR GRAIN EXPORTS TO CARRY OUT
THESE ATTACKS.
PUTTING THAT ASIDE, THEY RODE
FORMALLY TO THE UN BUT IN THE
MEANTIME, WE'VE TALKED TO THE
UKRAINIANS AND CONVEYED THE
DEMANDS OR EXPECTATIONS OF THE
RUSSIAN SIDE OF THE UKRAINIANS.
TO GIVE THEM CREDIT ACTUALLY
BOTH SIDES TOOK A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE APPROACH AFTER
SEEING THAT SUSPENDING THIS
AGREEMENT WILL BE IN EVERY
BODIES LOSS OR --
IT WILL COST THEM DEARLY.
AS A RESULT.
THEY COME BACK TO THE AGREEMENT
AND AFTER THE CALL WITH
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND PRESIDENT
ERDOGAN.
NOW WE HAVE EVERYTHING BACK ON
TRACK.
>> SO WHAT DEMANDS THAN --
WHAT GUARANTEES THAT RUSSIA
WANT AS PART OF ITS RETURN.
I WANT TO PLAY IF I COULD JUST
A LITTLE SOUNDBITE.
A CLIP OF WHAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
SAID TODAY.
HAVE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> [INTERPRETER]
IN THIS REGARD, I HAVE
INSTRUCTED THE DEFENSE MINISTRY
TO RESUME OUR PARTICIPATION IN
THIS WORK.
HOWEVER, RUSSIA RESERVES THE
RIGHT TO WITHDRAW FROM THESE
AGREEMENTS IF THESE GUARANTEES
OUR BREACHED BY UKRAINE.
IN ANY CASE, EVEN IF RUSSIA
PULLS OUT OF THIS DEAL, WE WILL,
AS WE SAID EARLIER, BE READY TO
SUPPLY THE ENTIRE VOLUME OF
CRANE THAT WAS SUPPLIED FROM
UKRAINE TO THE POOREST
COUNTRIES.
WHICH IS ONLY 4%.
>> COLIN, LET ME JUST CLARIFY.
DID RUSSIA ASK FOR WRITTEN
GUARANTEES THAT UKRAINE WILL
NOT USE THE HUMANITARIAN
CORRIDOR FOR MILITARY PURPOSES?
IS THIS WHAT IT WAS DEMANDING?
>> YES, THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THAT WAS FOR THE NEGOTIATIONS
WERE ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT WAS ACHIEVED.
IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
AND WE HOPE THAT BOTH SIDES
WILL STICK TO THE AGREEMENT.
THE AGREEMENT WAS SIGNED ABOUT
THREE MONTHS AGO.
WE HOPE THAT THEY WILL CARRY
THIS TO THE EXTENSION OF THE
AGREEMENT WHICH WILL COME UP IN
ABOUT TWO WEEKS.
BECAUSE IT'S IN EVERYBODY
CENTRIST.
AND IN FACT, WE'VE BEEN SAYING
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING THAT AS
PART OF THE AGREEMENT, NO
MILITARY ACTIVITY SHOULD BE
CARRIED OUT IN AND AROUND THE
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDOR FOR GRAIN
EXPORTS.
WE HOPE THAT THIS WILL BE THE
CASE.
THAT'S WHAT THE RUSSIANS
DEMANDED.
THAT'S WHAT THEY GOT.
THE GRAIN INSIDE HAS BEEN VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE.
OUR PRESIDENTIAL SPOKE TO
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ABOUT THIS.
AND THEY WENT OVER THIS.
AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ALSO
CONFIRMED THEIR COMMITMENT TO
THE AGREEMENT.
BUT OF COURSE, THE MAJOR
DIFFERENCES REMAIN ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE WAR.
ON THE FUTURE OF THE WAR.
WHAT MAY UNFOLD IN THE DAYS TO
COME.
THE GRAIN EXPORT DEAL --
THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR EVERYBODY.
>> YOU CAN BE ASSURED THAT
RUSSIA WON'T PULL OUT OF IT
AGAIN.
HOW MUCH, COLIN, DID THE UN
CONTINUE ON THE DEAL.
TURKEY CONTINUE ON WITH THIS
DEAL.
HOW MUCH OF THAT BASICALLY
CALLS PUTIN'S BLUFF?
WAS THAT AN ELEMENT OF PERHAPS
PUTIN MAKING A DECISION TO
RETURN?
>> IT MAY OR NOT BE.
BUT RESIDENT HAS BEEN MAKING A
CRITICAL POINT ABOUT THE DEMAND
OF GRAIN GOING --
UNDERDEVELOPED COUNTRIES.
AS HE JUST SAID IN THE VIDEO
THAT HE JUST PLAYED.
THEY'VE BEEN RAISING THIS ISSUE.
IF THE IDEA WAS TO GET THE
GRAIN EXPORTS FERTILIZERS AND
OTHER GRAIN PRODUCTS.
TO THOSE IN NEED IN AFRICA AND
OTHER PLACES.
WHY ARE THE EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
GETTING MORE --
ALMOST HALF OF THE UKRAINIAN
GRAIN.
THAT'S A POLITICAL POINT.
OF COURSE, IT'S UKRAINE'S
GRAIN.
THEY CAN SELL IT TO WHOEVER
THEY WANT TO.
BUT AS FAR AS THE INTERNATIONAL
GREEN MARKETS ARE CONCERNED.
WHEN THE OPERATIONS START.
EVEN IN A MATTER OF FOUR DAYS.
THE GRAIN PRICES WENT UP.
AND THE SENSE IN FACT UNTIL
THEN.
OVER THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
THE GRAIN PRICES WERE GOING
DOWN.
SO I THINK IT SHOWS HOW
SENSITIVE THIS ISSUE IS.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE OTHER PART
OF THE DEAL WHICH IS THE
RUSSIAN FERTILIZERS AND GRAIN
EXPORTS THAT NEED TO BE
EXPORTED TO INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN FACING
SOME ISSUES AND PROBLEMS.
THERE IS NO FORMAL EMBARGO ON
RUSSIA EXPORTS.
SHIPPING COMPANIES, INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND OTHER LOGISTICAL
COMPANIES.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF SECONDARY
SANCTIONS.
THEY'RE KIND OF STAYING AWAY
FROM DOING ANY BUSINESS WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
AS THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
WE'VE BEEN TELLING OUR EUROPEAN
FRIENDS COLLEAGUES IN EUROPE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU WANT THE GRAIN TO
CONTINUE AND GET THE RUSSIAN
GREEN AND FERTILIZERS,
INCLUDING AMMONIA, GO OUT TO
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKETS.
THEY HAVE TO BE GIVEN SOME
ASSURANCES.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE AGREED
TO RUSSIA'S WAR PLANES OR THE
PURPOSE OR GOAL OF THIS WAR IN
ANY WAY.
BUT AS FAR AS THE GREEN DEAL IS
CONCERNED, IN ORDER TO PROTECT
IT.
I THINK THEY WILL HAVE TO BE
GIVEN SOME ASSURANCES.
THOSE COMPANIES ANOTHER
SUDDENLY UKRAINIAN BUT ALSO
RUSSIAN EXPORTS CAN GO OUT.
SO THAT EVEN TONIGHT AT THE
MARKETS KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU FINALLY, A
FINAL QUESTION.
YOU AND I HAVE HAD VARIOUS
CONVERSATIONS ALREADY THIS
YEAR.
AND AS I'VE MENTIONED IN OUR
PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS, TURKEY
IS EMERGING AS KIND OF THE
DOMINANT PLAYER IN THIS GRAIN
DEAL.
MAKING A BIG DIPLOMATIC WHICH
IS WELL.
THIS IS THAT YOU AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED.
WHERE ARE WE ON THIS?
WHAT IS PRESIDENT ERDOGAN
TELLING PRESIDENT PUTIN?
WHAT IS HE ADVISING HIM IN
TERMS OF THE WAR AND WHERE THE
STATE WE'RE AT IN THE WAR RIGHT
NOW.
>> OUR PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SPEAKING TO PRESIDENT PUTIN AND
ZELENSKYY ON A REGULAR BASIS.
AND ADVISING BOTH SIDES TO
DE-ESCALATE TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE.
I KNOW THIS SOUNDS A BIT NAIVE.
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
WAR.
BUT OUR ASSESSMENT IS THAT THIS
IS WHAT OUR PRESIDENT HAS
COMMITTED BOTH LEADERS IN HIS
VARIOUS CONVERSATIONS INCLUDING
CALLING PRESIDENT PUTIN
YESTERDAY AND THE CALL THAT
JUST HAPPENED WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY TODAY.
THAT THERE IS NO REALLY
MILITARY BREAKTHROUGH HERE.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE EITHER
SIDE IS ABLE TO HAVE A DECISIVE
VICTORY ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THE LONGER THIS WAR CONTINUES,
THERE MIGHT BE ATTACKS.
DIFFERENT TACTICS, DIFFERENT
BOMBINGS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT THEY WILL ALL END UP
CREATING MORE DESTRUCTION AND
LOSS FOR BOTH SIDES.
THREE MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD, SIX
MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD.
WE HAVE DISCUSSED ON THE SHOW.
WE WILL MEET AGAIN.
TALKING ABOUT THE NEED TO COME
BACK TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
BUT DURING THAT TIME, WE WILL
HAVE MANY MORE LOSSES OF LIFE.
TERRITORY AND DESTRUCTION OF
THE THINGS.
THE NUCLEAR THREAT IS A
POSSIBILITY.
OUR PRESIDENT HAS BEEN RAISING
THIS ISSUE WITH BOTH LEADERS
AGAIN.
HE SPOKEN TO PRESIDENT PUTIN
ABOUT THIS AND THEY DENIED OF
ANY INTENTION ON THEIR PART TO
GO NUCLEAR.
AND PRESIDENT SKI AGAIN
REITERATED THEIR POINT ALSO
THAT ITS ALLY TO CLAIM THAT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE PREPARING TO USE
DIRTY BOMBS, CHEMICAL UP,
UNSUCCESSFULLY.
BUT EVEN TO TOP OF IT IS A SIGN
OF DANGER.
WHEN THE STAKES ARE SO HIGH, I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
NOT ONLY FOR OUR PRESIDENT BUT
ALSO FOR OTHER WORLD LEADERS TO
TAKE A MORE REALISTIC APPROACH,
AND ASSESSMENT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENT ERDOGAN
HAS BEEN TELLING PRESIDENT
PUTIN.
AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
STAY AWAY FROM ANYTHING NUCLEAR,
CHEMICAL.
BUT ALSO TRY TO FIND A WAY FOR
A DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION.
WARS AND ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
EVEN AFTER YOU HAVE
NEGOTIATIONS.
OR THEY AND WITHIN NEGOTIATIONS
GET SERIOUS.
--
>> LET'S HOPE THEY WERE
LISTENING.
LET'S HOPE PUTIN WAS LISTENING
TO THAT.
ABRAHAM CO